that we're live i'll i'll introduce the
meeting
and i'll just bring paul i'll just bring
paul miller into the meeting
right counselors we've now had a
confirmation that um we're running live
on street
on youtube so um good evening and
welcome to the strata joint scrutiny
committee
all participants punts all participants
here today are taking part remotely and
we are live streaming this meeting on
youtube
we have no apologies at the moment but
councillors
um councillors jackie orm and nick
hookway might join us
later i will start with a roll call of
the committee members to confirm
attendance could members confirm
they are present when their name is
called please
so we've got councillor king
yeah i'm here thank you council atkinson
present councillor sparks
a present counsellor oliver
present cancer clarence
president councillor nuttal
thank you
right moving on to the agenda with the
appointment of a chair
could i ask for nominations please
okay so on the basis that uh it's exeter
and there's only two here
um yvonne atkinson is definitely the
most senior counselor she's prepared to
take it on i'd like to propose her as
chair for the next year
thank you phil thank you and if i could
second that
place yeah sorry who was who was that i
didn't see who that was okay so
councillor sparks thank you
okay so um cancer atkinson's been um
nominated by councillor twist and
seconded by councillor sparks
are there any other nominations please
this isn't a nomination just to say that
i'm from exeter as well so i'm a third
person
i do apologize trisha didn't see you
there that's okay
okay um there's no other nominations can
we do a
vote on that please and if you're happy
to show um
your hands um we did a vote by hands
okay that looks like that looks like
most people are there any
against if you'd like to say
if you're against or any abstentions if
you'd like to
shout if you're abstaining that's fine
so
that's council accusing this julie um
elected so i'll hand over to you
that's atkinson councillors thank you um
for your nomination and vote i'm i'm now
going to move to item three which is
minutes of the last meeting which is
13th of january 2020.
um the minutes are attached to the
agenda
are these minutes correct
um okay so i think we need do we need a
show
of hands to um say they are correct
trish what i'm gonna do
is i think i'll go to if anybody
dissents
as to their correctness please speak
uh in the absence of that i'm going to
assume unanimity
thank you
we have today next item is public
questions and i haven't been notified
that there are oh sorry
declarations of interests um has anybody
got any interest they'd like to declare
which relate to the business on the
agenda
thank you the next is item five which is
questions from the public under
procedural rules
and i haven't been advised that there
are any questions
from the public the next item
is item six questions from
members of the respective councils and i
understand that councillor
paul miller is present and would like
to ask some questions
so i'm going to ask councillor miller
to read out his first question
uh thank you very much um i've received
answers to the written
questions um i i only wish to ask
one supplementary okay so
let's take the question at a time so
question one is there a supplementary to
question one to the answer to question
one
can you remind me of the uh i've just
got my zoom in front of me unfortunately
another device to uh
um
let me see um i've just forgotten which
order they're in that's all yeah
we need to read them actually put it out
before i read them out
um so i'm trying to get my screen to
minimize so i can actually access the
questions
so i can access the questions unless you
see
lauren's here hopefully people can see
the screen
which is the questions and the responses
can everybody see that or not
no it's just the agenda no i'm afraid
not
right
now that you've put um your screen
share on i can't actually minimize my
screen
to access the questions um i just wonder
if you could perhaps
come out of the yeah and then like
okay thank you right so the first
question was to ask the committee to
confirm the total cost of purchasing
member ipads at east devon district
council
including maintenance and repairs and to
share all relevant papers containing the
business case
with councillors you've had a response i
do have a supplementary to that
yes i do i just want firstly to thank
the committee
and the strata staff for providing such
a
uh accurate and comprehensive response
to my question
uh my supplementaries to the committee
and perhaps um councillor twis
um was in the administration at the time
um so this decision
on the east seven ipads was taken in
2018
i understand that councilor twist has
actually given his ipad back
uh to east devon and i'm looking at the
figures and this this seems to have now
cost uh east evan district council um 80
over 80 000 pounds um because because
obviously
we had the ipads um first of all
and then there was the cost for the
remote
office 365. um so i just wanted to ask
a counselor twist at the time um that
decision
which was made in 2018 how how open was
it
between members and strata or was it
something that he
he didn't know about at the time um
because i'm just concerned about the
public cost
of these ipads and the escalating public
cost it seems to them so that's my
supplementary on that one
uh i'm not sure you can address that to
counsel a twist actually that must be
addressed to officers so
can you answer that officers
uh it's lawrence here um i guess
probably
um simon as the representative for east
evan who sits on the strata board
um and also would have been involved in
the
um justification this was a proposal
that strata put
to the uh authorities back in 2018 to
improve the support of councillor i.t um
obviously we put we put a number of
options and those options were discussed
at joint scrutiny and joint executive
and uh
simon on behalf of east devon could you
talk through
the process by which um uh
the decision was made and ratified to
move forward with the ipads
is it okay to answer that question thank
you
for that introduction lawrence most
helpful so um
the as lawrence has provided the papers
it was obviously discussed
at um the joint executive
strata or minutes of those meetings then
go on to
eastern district council's own cabinet
so those papers would have been
presented to east devon's cabinet for
approval which they were
because it was a request for money it
then would have been wrapped up in a
budget process
so that again would have gone back to
cabinet within the council's budget
for approval onto overview
and scrutiny committees and then to full
council for decision
so it's been through the full democracy
if you like of the stem district council
and approving that spend
thank you the next question
um is
i'll just read it out
um what progress they
i uh to ask the committee what progress
i suppose we are making
in assessing the potential for hybrid
meetings
um council you've had a full response in
writing together with a report is there
a supplementary question
no having received the answer an hour
ago i think i'll read the report first
and maybe ask us um a pursuant question
at a future meeting if um
if i need to no supplementary to that
thank you very much
we are we have got a slide and i have
asked pete john's during my
presentation just to cover off uh
virtual meetings and hybrid meetings
as to what progress is being made so it
might well be that we'll answer
uh any supplementary questions as part
of our presentation this afternoon
okay thank you the third question is to
ask the committee have any town and
parish councils in the district
approach strata or support for support i
suppose
since the coronavirus act 2020
and you've received a response and the
response is that
there have been no requests do you have
a
supplementary question no supplementary
to that thank you chair
the fourth question is to ask the
committee does it remain the policy
to wind up the strata joint scrutiny
committee
and has this been assessed in terms of
transparency remember democratic
oversight
again you've had a full answer
and several reports which go back to uh
review of governance going back um
to the end of last year do you have a
supplementary question
yes i do um in the in the sense that i i
just
ask that the committee um look at this i
don't think now is the time
uh to reduce um the amount of scrutiny
on
what has become a very important um
you know company and an arm of all
councils the it departments you know
we're all now
used to working virtually and i think i
think the scrutiny of strata is really
really very important
i have read the report i just i just
like to ask whether
whether there can be a reconsideration
given of course we are we are now living
in good
in new times having been a member of
this scrutiny committee for
for the last year um you know i think
it's done a really really good job
and uh i'd like it to continue thank you
thank
you
um the situation is that we haven't
actually considered this have we did we
i'm we haven't actually considered that
report here at this scrutiny meeting
have we
we did discuss that report plus it went
in front of the
joint executive committee in june for
consideration so it's certainly
something that has been on the agenda
that we've been looking at
um and it was basically suggested that
we move forward
and we engage so we engage the team
bridge legal team who provide legal
support to strata
and we've actually gone through the
stakeholder agreement
and the um the of strata to look at how
do we actually
change the overall governance structure
but um
with the with the covid pandemic um
it's been one of those areas that uh
we've had to focus on the key priorities
of strata which hasn't necessarily at
this stage
been re-engineering the governance
framework uh
it's been focusing on ensuring that we
continue to deliver the
services that we have so it's not
something we push forward currently
um i do did we actually make a
recommendation from this committee to
approve
um our abolition or i don't remember we
making that
us making that recommendation but a lot
has happened
um it was discussed and uh councillor
twists as the
former chairman i know you were quite
supportive and it was discussed in quite
a lot of detail
uh in the last meeting we held in um
team bridge in february
i think we just have to pull the minute
yeah okay sorry that was a meeting i
missed sorry that's why yeah
okay thank you i think i'm very
conscious that
times have changed significantly over
the last five months and
uh i've got a board meeting with the uh
three board members on friday
and it is one of the agenda items that
i've put down and maybe
we can take on board some of the
questions to the points that have been
raised
and maybe have another look at that
governance framework if you'd like us to
okay um yes come in there
sorry check who who is it sorry
me steven right um just to say that
although
because he went through scrutiny and the
recommendation was was approved
it went through the joint executive
committee and it wasn't at that stage
but just to clarify he would need to go
back to all three councils
for agreement so all three councils will
have that chance for debate
once the work has been done in terms of
what the constitution would look like
because it's constitutional changes for
each authority
so there is time for that debate and
consideration to take place
at each authority in terms of members if
that helped
yeah and and chairman i've got my hand
up and i've got the blue hand on
sorry could i ask you because i've got a
list of participants and
if you raise your hand on the screen i
can't i can't see uh that's where i can
see you if you put it
use the r raised hand facility on zoom
rather than yeah i've got it up on zoom
at the moment
so i wanted to speak on that okay sorry
yeah um if you look at the participants
you should see the blue hands there
yeah i've only got chris clarence
showing that's me that's me
that is you is it okay sorry yeah well i
don't
i don't ever remember what lawrence had
to say
as far as i know we never met in
february the last time we met
and having read the minutes was the 13th
of january
that was the last ons meeting we had and
i don't ever remember talking about
dismantling ons strata but you know man
i do fall asleep at some meetings a bit
um hopefully i didn't fall asleep at
this one
right if i may help on that there was a
duplication which is why it seemed to
have the second thing we were talking
about is being superfluous to the need
that's as i i recall it but it should be
somewhere within the minutes i i would
think
i will not have to go back it does the
minutes say the paper would be discussed
between the three council leaders chief
executives
of ecc edc and tdc
any agreement to propose changes in the
strata government's model
would be implemented from the first of
april the report is noted
so we actually just noted the report we
didn't make a recommendation
which was um what i thought
well done okay so please call me chair
okay thank you so um so yes so hopefully
we should have that back on the agenda
and i presume when um
um uh
uh mr whitlock said things have changed
is that because we're now
meeting virtually we're not all it's not
all necessary to go to team bridge
from across the county is that the main
difference
um i i i don't know but no doubt that
will come back to us
perhaps we could have it on the next um
agenda if that's possible
yes okay thank you right
um so we now if that's all right
thank you um paul for uh your questions
and i want to thank i want to thank the
strata team and the committee for
what were excellent written answers um
which obviously took a lot of time
thank you very much okay
thank you um the next item um
the local government act um i think um
is in the wrong place um
because we're not excluding the press
and public from discussion of items
eight nine or ten um so i'm going to
take that item before
item eleven so we're now moving on to
item eight which is strata ita
it director and managers report and
that's pages 9 to 40
of your agenda pack and we've got a
presentation thank you
uh good afternoon everybody um uh i've
put together some slides to sort of talk
you through what we've been doing over
the last uh
uh well it'll be eight months since we
last met um
obviously can everybody see um the slide
deck that
uh hopefully is now appearing
did everybody see that supporting the
officers yeah brilliant
excellent thank you um so
obviously um i don't think any of us
quite expected
um in january um to be in this position
sort of nine months later
um but certainly from strata's point of
view um
as i said at a recent uh joint exec the
last joint exec
you know there comes a time for a
business that can really show what its
true value is and
i really hope that over the last um sort
of five to six months
transfer has really supported not just
the work of the officers but hopefully
supported yourselves as councillors
but helping you support the citizens and
businesses
of devon there's been a huge amount of
work that's been going on and the key
focus of strata
has been to offer you that support to
enable you to carry on and do the
outstanding jobs that you do as officers
and councillors
of the three authorities that we support
so that's been the primary theme
um as a high level summary of
you know where where we've been over the
last eight months and i think this has
been
um you know at no time in my 40-year
career have i
understood the real importance of it
to deliver in an exemplary way
a a you know a complete end-to-end
service in the support
of businesses in such pandemics so um
you know it's not something that we
created overnight i think
the technology choices that were made
five years ago at the inception of
strata
and the authorization from joint exec
and joint scrutiny to create strata and
also to you know free up the money to
enable the investment
set you up really well to be able to
operate during the pandemic
those decisions made whether it be the
introduction of skype for business
whether it be the introduction of the
global desktop the investment in data
centers
the investment in the tools to ensure
that the the network and the
applications was highly secure i think
you know was exemplary was was a really
great decisions
um and also i think the creation of
strata
created that skill set and that
knowledge base that has really supported
you
throughout the uh throughout the last
you know few months
um so i think that's a you know that's a
great thing and it i
feel really really fortunate to be at
the at the front of an organization that
has achieved so much over this period of
time and that's really down to the staff
that we employ
um we had um last year um
the savings that we delivered were well
in excess of what we originally
uh put forward as part of the business
plan what the were originally put
forward as part of the strata
original business plan so we delivered
over 1 million pounds worth of savings
last year
and that's been fully signed off by the
auditors as well
but we've created this environment that
enabled us to flex and change and adapt
very very quickly to the needs of the
authority so
whether it be the creation of the
community hubs across each of the
authorities
whether it be the crew you know the the
work that we've done
um on supporting councillors and
officers with virtual council meetings
and as we move forward potentially with
hybrid meetings
enabling staff to be able to move from
being in an office to remote working
pretty much seamlessly over a period of
about two weeks
uh is testament to the excellent um
you know infrastructure choices that
were made
we've had to do a huge amount of work on
provisioning
i.t in a difficult climate
a lot of laptops were provisioned to
enable officers to be able to work and
operate from home
we've had to use you know very strong
procurement processes
to enable us to procure hardware to
support the work of the authorities
and i know that has been something that
has been proven very very challenging
for a lot of organizations
is to get hold of that critic equipment
at a critical time
but also to be able to ensure that
people can operate in a very safe and
secure way
but also we've done a lot of work in
working with yourselves about helping
and informing citizens through
through crisis and i think there's been
a fundamental
change about how citizens now work with
the authorities and there's been
a considerable move to a much more
digital way of working and
hopefully with the um work that we've
done with the authorities around
firmstep and and sort of customer
relationship customer interaction
the work that we've done around customer
contact center has really helped
you inform and guide and help your
citizens in
the businesses you support in this
really difficult time
um one of the things that we pride
ourselves on
is the availability of our systems it is
inherently
a a risk business it's in a business
that if you keep investing money
you will ensure a certain level of
stability of your infrastructure
and what we're really proud of is really
during the pandemic the availability
of our environment has pitching pretty
much stayed at a
100 percent available for most of the
time there's been a
a couple of little blips but overall the
performance has been exceptional of the
systems
um the graph that you can see in front
of you there which is a radar diagram
um works out from the center at 95
availability up to 100 availability and
what i've tried to demonstrate there
is that over the uh since the 1st of
september 2018
so a two-year window we're now at a time
where we've got an incredibly
stable reliable flexible and adaptable
environment that supports the works of
the officers
um but i thought what was key was really
to show you that
over a a very short period of time which
was
about nine days um we had about 25 to 30
percent of
officers accessing the global desktop
environment
um working from home point one
is a period starting on the first of
april where actually the three
authorities pretty much
moved officers to remote working
and how over the preceding periods of
time
we've actually seen that ability to
support workers remote
working remotely and we've seen in team
bridge over the last
few weeks um a slow move back of staff
into the office environment
but with exeter and e-7 still having
approximately 77
of their staff being able to work
remotely with team bridge having 52
working remotely and that is based on a
snapshot in time taken on a wednesday at
about 11 a.m in the morning
so that gives you an idea of the number
of uh officers
operating remotely but operating really
successful
in a safe and secure environment
obviously now
as people start to move back into the
office we are starting to see people
migrating
back into the office environment and
obviously what we do we monitor this on
a week by week basis
and i think we'll start to see more
people moving back into the office
environment but
the great thing about the global desktop
whether you're working remotely or
whether you're working in the office
you pretty much get exactly the same
experience
sometimes it can be limited by people's
ability or people's broadband services
at home
but they're outside the control of
strata but i thought that was a really
good picture to show you and
and this is enabling you to carry on
delivering the exceptional services that
you do
in a very difficult time um we found
that there has been a massive demand on
strata services
um on the left-hand side i took a
snapshot on the first of march which
is sort of pre-covered we had regularly
about 97
incidents coming in we had a number of
service requests which are requests for
new devices for licenses etc and we also
had a number of uh
business change requests what we have
actually seen
is that there's been a considerable
ramping up of the demands being made on
strata
over that sort of six month period of
time where the number of incidents
we've got has really exceeded what our
expectations were
however in february we implemented a new
service desk system
called b fire and that has really
enabled us to manage that demand coming
into strata
really effectively and whilst we
understand that maybe
you know um we're seeing a huge amount
of demand there
actually the resources we've got pretty
much keep on top of this on a day-to-day
basis
we manage customer satisfaction i've got
a graph to show you that later
but actually we're still finding that
officers are really
happy with the service that strata
continue
to deliver um
i thought it was worthwhile now um
is to ask a couple of the managers just
to give you a little bit of an update on
some of the key things that we've seen
over the last
you know few months and i think what was
important
is um as i said in a presentation the
other day
i've been selling uh or or promoting
um video desktop conferencing systems
since 1994.
um the last sort of seven to eight
months has seen a massive
requirement for a system that people
always thought was
nice to have but it's now an essential
um
and i think the success of the delivery
of the zoom meetings and and
uh yeah fully aware that the the
councillors at team bridge
um and the other authorities were really
keen on zoom as a product and i think we
realized fairly early on
that that was a product that we needed
to um you know
accept and build a solution around and i
think what you seem to have now
is a very good environment in which you
can have meetings such as this afternoon
but
can i maybe ask ask um robin or pete
could you maybe just talk a little about
about virtual meetings
but also about what we see is the next
step which is around
what we're terming hybrid council
meetings
beethoven robin yeah join me to speak so
uh yeah
there's virtual meetings to start with
so as lauren said
zoom is obviously the product of of
choice so that came about
through through a lot of testing that we
did and some
feedback we were getting from from
councillors um
so what we did is we worked very closely
with the three democratic services
departments we
we had regular meetings all together to
discuss how
to how to run it and how to deploy it
and through many many test meetings we
we did
several training sessions with with all
the counsellors from all three
authorities
and many supports calls after that as
well one-to-one calls
and from that when we actually started
going to live meetings
we sat and supported as many as we could
um
in the evenings so through that we were
making phone calls to councillors who
are dropping out or having certain
issues so
we did our absolute best to support
these meetings um
throughout going from physical meetings
to virtual
so that was a huge effort from our part
and also democratic services who were
brilliant
working with us um and the hybrid
meetings is the kind of next stage on to
that and
when i say hybrid meetings we mean uh
when some councillors are
are physically present in the council
chambers and and some are
virtual and um and any number in between
of
uh how many are physical or virtual uh
this presents quite a few challenges
i'll be honest um
depending on how many people are
physical in the in the council chambers
depends on what solution we put in place
so
uh to find a solution that's very
flexible to allow small numbers or large
numbers is is proving quite challenging
and so where we're going with this is
we're kind of working with team bridge
they're kind of taking the the charge
here
they invested in a solution pre-covered
for a webcasting solution
um which which just happens to to fit
the bill most of the way
and so we're working on on some of that
just to see how it how it plays
out so we've been doing some testing
with that and team bridge has been
leading
which we're hoping to have a bit more to
show maybe through october
um the recommendation we put a paper
together the recommendation is actually
for exeter
in east devon to to hold fire and just
just kind of observe what happens at
team bridge and even get involved in
some of the testing
just to see how it goes before investing
in any other solution because
it may may do the job and it might just
just save us the time looking elsewhere
that's where we are with hybrid
brilliant thank you that's uh most
useful
um i i we did a we did a big project for
team bridge um exeter had moved over to
um a very agile environment um
in the sort of um you know middle of
last year they made a decision to buy
laptops we provisioned those they were
all available
uh as of about february uh but with
inside team bridge it was fairly
um there were predominantly desktop
machines um and there wasn't necessarily
an ability
for staff to work in a in a mobile way
um we were asked by teambridge whether
we could help facilitate deliver
um about 100 laptops um adrian are you
adrian is our infrastructure manager
heads-up support adrian
are you happy just to quickly cover off
what we did for team bridge around
delivering an agile environment for them
yes i can do
yeah so as lawrence said the team bridge
was predominantly a desktop-based
solution so we worked with the
management team there to come up with a
new design
as a result of that we procured 100 new
laptops and 160
docking stations so as of this week
we've delivered just over 90 of those
laptops to staff now who are now using
those and we've converted about 110
desks
to be agile for staff with the new
laptops and existing laptops
by the end of the project which is only
a couple of weeks away around half of
the staff will now be equipped with a
laptop so they can work flexibly and
agile
and about two-thirds of the main
fordhaus
office and the depot are set up for
agile working as well which
has obviously been very successful um
previously to that obviously we were
relying on the goodwill of staff as
lawrence mentioned to use
personal devices which was a little bit
hit and miss because there's only so
much support
we can offer on a personal device but we
did invest in
additional software during kobe to allow
us to support those users
through the crisis that's where we are
thank you adrian um another project that
we've been looking at and this is
something that we've done
for um quite a while down the east devon
is what we term the digital mail room
um martin you martin heads up our
document center
uh team with inside strata marty could
you maybe just give us a little
covering of what the digital mail room
is and potentially the value that that
will be
certainly as we move through move
through
covid and with the way citizens now want
to interact with the authorities
yeah sure thanks laurence um yeah so the
digital mail rooms originally set up to
support east devon's move
to their new office in blackgun house
which which was
designed to be paperless since the
lockdown in march that was ramped up
so previously we were probably scanning
about 70 75
of posts coming in the building and
stopping that paper circulating
that's probably about 95 percent and
it's a very detailed process
process so members of public sending
anything and gets scanned the same day
and then distributed out to either
document management systems or
into department inboxes or occasionally
to
individual offices and that's all
detailed
those processes are detailed per
department
pulling on for that we've actually
started to introduce it to team bridges
council as well
there was some demand there just
naturally as people work from home
and we're developing that on an ongoing
basis so
it supports very well anyone working
from home
offices so pieces of posts coming in
if it comes in that day they'll have it
that day um nothing's held back
everything is scanned on the day
brilliant so again this is a strata
offering it's something that we
developed to east devon
but now team bridge are certainly making
use of it
um and hopefully it will just um drive
up efficiencies in the movement of paper
in a digital seamless way around the
authority so we thought you might be
interested in hearing a bit
about that there's another big project
that we have underway at the moment
which is
exeter leisure exeter are bringing back
in-house their leisure facilities
strata were asked if we could work with
the authority to
support that programme adrian you've
been uh pretty much involved in
are involved in that could you maybe
give us a little bit of an upgrade
update on how things are going with
extra leisure and what our involvement
is
absolutely so i think it was the end of
july exeter made us aware of the
leisure services coming back inside the
council
they presented us with a list of six
premises
and we were tasked with essentially they
were greenfield sites because the
existing contract provider was going to
remove
all existing kit telephony network
infrastructure
and so we've we've designed new sets for
each of those sites
um this week we're working on extra
arena in the iska center and we're
hopeful that they'll both be live ready
by the end of next week with extra city
council hopeful to get them
operational again by the 28th i believe
it's been a pretty challenging project
from our perspective because
making one site live is challenged to do
six within the space of eight weeks
has been quite challenging but we've you
know the strata model has enabled us to
pull the resources that we have together
to deliver that and we've worked with
our suppliers to get the equipment
we need um currently the only real
challenge we're having is with open
reach to get the connectivity into all
six sites on time
but we're working with them to deliver
that so at the moment
everything is on track to meet the dates
set by extra
city council brilliant thank you adrian
um i've asked robin um to talk
a little bit about the cyber threat
because there's a very high profile case
recently which is red car
and obviously cyber is something that is
constantly
on the back of our mind so robin as our
head of sort of security and compliance
maybe you could give us a
little bit of an update on on are we
likely to become another red car
fingers crossed not but also maybe some
of the things that we're seeing and
we're having to do to protect
the work of the officers and the
councillors robin
oh yes i'd never like to say anything
that would suggest that uh
we can always protect ourselves all the
time because that always brings stuff on
you
but in this particular case um yes this
made the press
pre pre-covered times it was actually
the time where
the c word in this case was cyber and
not covid
and we can't provide too much
information because there's a lot of
security information amongst this but
the background appears to be that they
were attacked
they had a lot of security in place uh
however unfortunately the criminals the
cyber criminals got to their backups
which is where all their data is stored
and so they effectively ransomed all the
all the data
and and what we have to do and what
organizations have to do
is to ensure that we actually have
strong backup processes where we
we get our data backed up to things like
tape
puts in safe places so that should we be
compromised
and something happens to this degree
even if you had to go back a week's
worth you could still bring your council
back up again from all those systems and
unfortunately in this particular
situation it appears
that whatever went wrong they didn't
have that backup infrastructure working
for them and they're unable to recover
this
and it's come at a horrendous price to
them i mean they've put this top of 10
million price against this
but these systems have been down some of
the services would probably never
recover
there will be data that was never going
to be got back so there's going to be
ongoing issues
so we very much have to ensure that this
is something that we cover
and one of the things we gained by
having strata was bringing
three different security teams together
from three different councils
and we actually specialize we have a
specialist team just looking after and
making sure our backups
are tested they run through and
just are there all the time and they're
kept off site all those type of
critical things that we need to put in
place so
i'll never wish to to actually bring
anything on us but
we do what we can the backups are the
crown jewels for me
our data is that and that's what we're
doing to put in place
however the cyber the cyber hole threat
i wouldn't say
it's it's changed particularly in terms
of it's not hugely more hugely less
we've just had a lot of covey type
emails emailed is the
the constant root that's that's the
general rule
whether you're a home user or whether
you're a business user
cyber criminals use those type of spam
emails
those phishing emails there's lots of
different things they do they're really
clever
and that's why we have to to invest a
lot in terms of managing
the mail route coming into us and
there's a the second bit of diagram
there's it doesn't particularly say a
huge amount
but at the moment about 40 percent of
our emails coming in
are actually rejected they're rejected
under all these different categories
a lot of them are just coming from
that's that huge gray area they just
come from places that are already known
to be sending out these types of
emails so as as an organization
we do take the cyber very very seriously
because it we can't afford not to and
one of the things that we did
and again with some things we put in
place for strata
we put in something called two-factor
authentication it's it's a type of
requirement nowadays but what it meant
was when those users moved home which is
what we needed them to do
we knew that they actually were secure
even if they were going to use their
personal equipment the infrastructure we
put in place
ensured that we had a high level of
security already wrapped around them
yes it wasn't as great as them being in
the office but it was still
secure enough and and that's the type of
the thing we're doing we just try to
make sure we keep on top of this
security
and we do this and that's why we have a
dedicated team to manage that
um don't know what else you'd like on
that lawrence but
i've only got a little bit for you there
robin some of the things we're doing
around
cyber awareness and the fact that we're
in what we term psn at the moment robin
yeah
okay so at the moment um we're going
through what
they call the public service network i.t
health check as part of the
yet another acronym code of connection
it's it's effectively the annual mot
that the government
um indicates undertakes against council
organizations
um and we're going through that this
week and they will bring in
or we bring in specialist attackers who
specialized
and trying to be losing uh you're losing
me are you
okay well i'll just continue anyway so
we bring in specialists in terms of
cyber
threats they test us out and
in effect if we can demonstrate that
we've got everything in place
they'll give us this certificate and we
need that to continue and every year we
get that certificate
and we're going through at the moment
one of the
areas that always seems to catch
organizations it's passwords
passwords passwords
sorry i don't know whether everybody
else is losing me or not but i can hear
you i can hear you i can hear you
yeah okay well okay sorry chris now
um so one of the things that is
passwords and we we
always get picked up with passwords and
one of the things we've we're putting in
place this year
is something a cyber awareness training
program for all the councils
all three of them and all the
councillors have access to this new
training module
and so that's something that's been
released at the moment just to try and
bring up that extra bit of level there
because at the end of the day we can put
as much security in terms of technical
software in place but it we as the users
we are that end stop in terms of
trying to stop this type of thing
happening to us as an organization
yeah yeah
okay brilliant thank you thank you robin
um i think that's useful
um and it's something that you know we
pride ourselves on the
the ability for strata to protect you
from the world of cyber but we also have
to need to ensure that
users are protecting themselves as well
and not leaving us
exposed and obviously the council system
is exposed
one of the areas that we put into place
uh or we spoke about we presented to the
joint scrutiny and joint exec
uh last year um was actually creating
what was termed an i.t
solution delivery team um david circum
who's on the court this afternoon david
created a project framework or
methodology under which we would deliver
our projects moving forward
um we've bought pete johnson and created
a solution delivery team pete's uh on
the call this afternoon and heads it up
we've now got far greater visibility of
our projects and
all the projects moving forward are
going to go through the methodology or
the process that we've been putting into
place
and it also enables us to much more
accurately understanding our resourcing
needs
moving forward so really very proud of
what
has been achieved in this team and also
how it will really help
to give much better control much better
management and much better oversight
of the project as they move through the
systems from
or as they move from sort of inception
somebody has an idea that gets a
business case raised
against funding um then we go through
procurement implementation
hello yes there's somebody trying to say
something sorry i think it's counselor
clearance
participants yeah it's
i i can't see anybody raising their
hands while the screen's on full i'm
afraid
no nor can i so did
did um did somebody want to speak
it's gone most of the time since rob
sorry council clarence you're fading in
and out so i'm going to ask you
sorry councillor clarence you'll fade
any in and out we can't
hear you so can i ask the officer to
continue
and you save your questions to the end
perhaps when the screen's not on full
we'll be able to ask questions
uh more easily fine
okay um every month we take
um user satisfaction based on the
feedback that we get
um from anybody who logs an instant with
strata
we manage that and we report it via our
monthly reporting processes to all
offices
this is a snapshot of the latest strata
satisfaction survey
the maximum score we can score on any
one question
is five as you can see there are
variations
over each of the months that we've been
recording um
and the the light the darkest green
color at the top that
is august um but we've been taking these
uh these snapshots for the last
um seven months and we're always
well over four uh we're normally over
four point five and occasionally we get
up to four point eight four point nine
and uh
we asked the question of how satisfied
are
um the end users with the service that
strata deliver how are how
happy are they with how long it took to
resolve the problems and
whilst we'll we'll never be perfect
because in our world it can never be
perfect
hopefully we're achieving a high level
of satisfaction
and that we're supporting the officers
and hopefully yourselves as counsellors
with the work that we do so hopefully
that gives you an idea of
the satisfaction that we're delivering
to customers
we also have to ensure and i guess this
is the role of
myself the strata managers and the
strata board that actually we're only as
good as the staff that we employ
um i believe we've got some exceptional
staff but we have to create an
environment in which people
can grow and blossom and and really
become the exceptional
staff and potential leaders that we all
need moving forward
um as it was really important to us um
during covid that we with all our staff
pretty much working from home we've had
about
85 to 90 percent of strata staff working
from home it was important
that as a business we understood the
impact on our staff so we carried out a
staff survey recently
and we got very encouraging results
basically to say that
um strata they felt that as strata we
had a great willingness and flexibility
to support
the work of the councils and to be uh
adaptive
uh during the during the crisis um the
the managers
hopefully we've demonstrated the
capabilities and the confidence
um to really lead strata forward as an
organization through a very difficult
time
that actually the values that were
created five years ago
really pretty much underpinned strata i
think we've we've created a company with
a very strong culture
um with very good leaders uh but also
staff who really have bought into the
overall strata vision and i think that
reflects
in you know we have a very low staff
attrition rate
but we also have an incredibly low staff
sickness level as well which i think is
great reflection of
how eager people are to do to a good job
and also 94 percent of people felt that
strata were
strata managers were communicating very
effectively we have a daily call
for about 10 to 15 minutes all staff are
invited on
uh that proves really effective we do
monthly
um updates i do an ip director's blog
and
we even did a strata walk on satellite a
socially distant strata walk over
um dartmoor um and it was lovely to see
some faces though i hadn't seen for a
while
and actually we all enjoyed just each
other's company catching up
and actually getting fit getting some
fresh air
and enjoying you know enjoying being
strata and being the organization that
we are
we also invest in our people as well
we've just put 12 members of strata
staff
through a very intensive eight-month uh
ilm
program so that's a leadership and
management program
and all those staff have achieved the
level five accreditation and i'm
starting to see
that level of accreditation and that
knowledge that we've gained by those 12
members of staff doing that training
really starting to help move strata
forward and i think it was really
critical in this time of crisis
that we had that strong leadership not
just at the senior level
but also throughout the strata
organization helping colleagues helping
the councils helping um you know
councillors really achieve what they
needed to achieve
um we talked briefly earlier on about
the strata governance model
i really just wanted to put this slide
in there to say that yes we know we
spoke about strata governance
we were looking at the governance
framework i've got a board meeting as we
mentioned earlier on
on friday and governance is one of those
areas that we're going to be looking at
and
i take on board the question that
councilman miller raised and your own
comments council atkinson
regarding scrutiny and obviously
understanding
how how the leaders and the executive
and the councillors want strata to be
governed moving forward
every year we have to produce the strata
business plan i know the current plan
is going through sign off it's been
signed off by exeter
and by east devon and i believe it's
going forward
for ratification by team bridge
at the end of september but
obviously we're now working on next
year's plan last year's plan was created
without us
even thinking that covid was around the
corner this year's plan the 2021-2022
plan
will obviously take into account some of
those changes that we've seen as a
result of covid much more of a move to
digital
much more of a collaboration
collaborative type approach with inside
the offices and the authorities
the need for virtual meetings hybrid
meetings etc so um we've now kicked off
that process of creating the plan for
next year
and that's the schedulers as to when
we're actually looking to create it
and to deliver it to to the councils for
review
ratification and approval and
that's really my it director's report um
obviously open the floor if anybody's
got any questions please don't hesitate
to ask
myself and obviously i've got all my
managers with me as well on the board
here
who would be more than happy to answer
them so could i ask you to come out of
the screen of course again thank you
okay so i've got two people with their
hands up
virtue i don't know which one did it
first so i'm just going to take the
order on the screen council currents
yeah well
oh dear we're losing you uh councillor
clarence um
and i'm i'm trying to speak
um we can't hear you can i suggest that
you write your question you know
that and now i can read it out
did you hear me this meeting because the
device
counselor clarence we can't hear you
you're intermittent and
yes council clowns we can't hear you
you're intermittent
device has become intermittent yes um so
what i was going to what i'm suggesting
is that you
put your question in a chat and i'll
read it out
so if you
you know how to do the chat facility
all right he's hopeless
can you use the chat facility
and i just need to be a part of this
meeting
so um councillor clarence if you go to
the screen at the bottom of the screen
and
put your shutter on you will see a chat
uh as a um
a box it's absolutely hopeless with a
chat
there so if you write your question i'll
read it out
um yvonne sorry to be the party how do
you spell the
device
can you put your hand up rather rather
than just
interrupt so
hello can you hear me tall
right is that council current
my machine is completely intermittent it
fades out
all the time i might just as well not be
a part of this meeting with this device
that i've got
it sounds like it's a problem with your
um internet connection
um do you want to say your question
now now we've got good i hadn't got a
connection i was just trying to tell you
i was completely ineffective at this
meeting because of the fact that
unable to listen to what's going on and
all the rest of it
so okay could i be sorry oh quick
your apologies accepted could i ask one
of the officers to give councillor
clarence a call at the end of the
meeting to try and iron out some of the
technical difficulties he's experiencing
for the next meeting
um i did see somebody else with a hand
up though it's
keith sparks council sparks
thanks joe just wonder if it's possible
for councillor clarence to dial in on
the telephone
uh it's obviously interesting problems
all right so do you have a question
yourself
i don't have a question for myself but i
think what number
i can come back now what number would i
be dialing if
you can help i'm sorry counselor you
can't
do this in the middle of a meeting i
wonder if um one of the officers can
um perhaps give you a call on your
mobile and give you
some advice please do yeah okay
thank you so i've got councillor twist
thank you vaughn i was trying to put
raise my hand but the function isn't
working on this particular
version so i'm just going to wave at you
oh no it is working
okay uh okay because it's saying raise
my hand it's not that thank you
i should turn it off right so my
question actually goes back to
password changes i know that there are
different schools of thought on that
whether you should change them
frequently or not my
my view is you should change them quite
frequently certainly for dcc we get a
forced reminder
on our lenovo kit uh which comes in i
think and ivan again you can you can
probably help with this i think it's
every eight weeks
where it's um not forced it's suggested
that we change our passwords to access
the kit
i think that's actually quite decent
practice so i know we talked about it
earlier in the meeting i don't know what
the
rest of the groups think what's the rest
of the code you think but i think it's
good practice to do that
thank you very much chef
jeff one of the officers thank you to
respond
yeah i promise probably as a security
it's actually um
yeah there's obviously been multiple
schools of thoughts and years gone by
um that was definite and i remember
changing my password every 30 days
that was the norm um times have changed
into a degree
um this is ncsc advice nowadays
national cyber security center advice um
that we don't change passwords what
we're trying to do now
is to make the passwords challenging
enough
so that they can't be guessed but ones
that you're not
constantly having to change and what
people tend to do is they tend to change
them because they're forced to every 30
days or 90 days is pretty much the
maximum
and then because it's a challenge to
change your password and remember it you
would then
write it down of course and that type of
goes against
all the good practice because you don't
want people doing that what we want
people to do
is to come up with good passwords that
aren't very easy to crack um all the
council users now
all the all the um officers are having
to use
15 character passwords but rather than
this gobbledygook which is what we used
to have you know used to have an a an
uppercase something a minus sign or
something
ncs guidance is very much about using
their their they
their suggestion is three random words
within those three random words put some
symbols
but don't try and do a three for an e or
something like that because
crackers love that that's what they do
they know what us
us humans do we try and make words and
just change the odd number
so what they're saying is use normal
words three words for a phrase
don't make them words that you
particularly um there's any
sequence between them use a space
potentially
use numbers here and there but add them
don't just replace them
that becomes something that will take
years for a good cracker to
to actually crack we're a council at the
end of the day if we were banking it
might be a little bit different here
but we're councils we're not generally
challenged at that level there's no it's
not worth somebody spending
hours and years of processing time to
try and crack what we've got here
so that's the change ncsc if you look on
their website it's very
much about this it's not about changing
your password any longer
it's about getting a good strong
password once that you can remember
that once you learn to type it you've
got this thing called muscle memory so
you'll remember your passwords quite
well once you've typed it for the 20th
time you probably won't even have to
think about it from there onwards it
just happens at that point
um do that and only change your
passwords if you've got any concerns
that it's been compromised if it might
have been written down or you think
somebody might have
somehow got into that particular account
you don't know how or why
change your password there come to the
service desk let us get it all sorted
for you
we'll check that through my team with a
specialist that if we actually pick
anything up
we'll take you through that we'll even
assist at the top of home side because
we are
very aware that passwords that sometimes
are used at home
can be used to work they must they
should never be but humans are human so
we type of we'll pick up all of that but
that's where the device is very much
changed
and it's ncsc advice i can't talk for
devon county
all organizations have obviously got
their own policies they wish to put in
place
but we're just following their guidance
that's all thank you very much
if i may that that actually is very
useful information
we know that but obviously it would be
much better to share that with um
everybody else as well on the three
councils if that's a recommendation from
strata then i think that should be
shared
it's not just a recommendation if you
the newsletter and i can't remember the
east devin newsletter but i can remember
exeter and
teambridge definitely sent this out in
part their members newsletters just to
say that is the guidance all staff for
the three councils have had that
and in fact we've just gone through a
password reset process
because um we actually did testing as my
security team
and we've actually found passwords which
were not up to scratch
and so we've targeted a whole load of
individuals
to get those passwords changed so
they're actually much more secure
thank you very much thank you as and any
other council have got any questions
and raise your hands
um just want to ask if council clarence
has managed to
um stay with us
okay hi there i'm on the phone to him
now trying to get okay all right thank
you
um if i've got a few questions um
what was the main reason for
counsellors dropping out of meetings as
in the case this particular case
and and what's the solution that's my
first question
and the second question is um
i've understand there could be a problem
with global
um the global working um
um platform um that
um i understand you know is available at
our council offices though not
in our home that sometimes it tends to
pixelate
um a and um so you can't actually see
the screen
very well um is that something you're
investigating
and then in my third question is in
relation to
cyber attacks clearly the um
red car in cleveland cost was 10 million
pounds
is it possible to um
to ensure against cyber attack
um and are we insured against cyber
attacks
um because that would be a hefty sum to
pay out should it happen to us
and um if not why not
those are my questions um right so
adrian could i maybe ask you to cover
off the
first two points maybe with pete pete
john's and robin helping out
so the first one was regarding about the
dropping out of meetings so
um adrian could you possibly cover that
off for me
i mean if if you're referring
specifically to zoom
um which is obviously the platform of
choice we're using at the moment
uh we don't have any control over it
it's
a complete third-party private platform
so the general issues would be around
bandwidth
and internet connectivity or users
actual devices connecting in but in
terms of the platform and its
reliability
strata has absolutely no access or
influence within it um obviously we
deployed our own
skype for business meeting platform
which is the one we do control
we don't control zoom unfortunately
okay um i just wonder if one
one one bit of advice that can be given
to councillors is to make sure you're
not relying on broadband but you are
actually
plugged in through an ethernet
collection uh because that might
increase um in my case it it helped
um okay thank you for that i can answer
the question
as well yeah yeah so yes we are aware at
the moment of an intermittent issue with
global desktop
that can manifest in various forms
either freezing
pixelation or a black screen we have
finally conclusively identified what
that problem is
and as of this week we're now starting
to roll out the fix
unfortunately the fix requires us to
upgrade
uh the software on every single council
device so we've got to upgrade nearly 2
000 devices to do that
so we are bringing in an additional
member of staff to assist with that so
we can do it quicker
and that program has started this week
and we've started with the users
that have been the worst effective and
have got incidents logged on the service
desk but
so we are rectifying that now
okay thank you and the final question
was around
cyber and cyber insurance um robin do
you think you could
handle that question for us and i know
it's one we've spoken about
in quite a lot of detail previously
robin
yeah and and no surprise since cleveland
and red car
um there's been a number of insurance
companies contacting us
yeah it's something we've looked at over
quite a few years actually because it's
always something that
various insurance companies will try and
sell to us
the challenge we find with these
insurances is the
cost that you need to pay towards that
insurance
versus the stipulations in effect that
you have to go through to actually meet
that because they don't do this they
realize that cyber is
quite an expensive impact to an
organization
so they don't obviously do that lightly
in terms of giving you something that
they will
definitely have to pay out on so when
we've looked at it and we've
say we've actually had a presentation to
the strata board or about
16 months ago something like that yeah
where
um we've gone through this it's been
quite evident quite quickly that
yes you can get this but what you'll
actually get back from that insurance
should something happen
is another thing altogether in terms of
red car and cleveland
it's how much of that was real costs
which you could attribute to
lost equipment and time to
rectify that versus some of the costs
which are very
hard to ensure or come up with a value
and that's the loss of their data
so it's is that is that juggling trick
at the moment
what we can see is it doesn't seem to be
a worthwhile investment what is
worthwhile investing is making sure
that we have things like our backups in
place and that we have
all the type of security software and
some of these systems which a lot of
councils can't afford we've got
something called a sim
here i'm not going to go into it but
effectively it's a huge
product that looks across the whole site
to look for odd things happening
we have one of those in place for the
three councils there's very few who
actually can put that type of system in
place
so that's generally where the investment
is we'll continue to look at this i know
all three councils have asked to look at
this
and it's something i would thought
whether it's this board meeting or the
next one we'll come up back on
the agenda again okay thank you um
phil is your phil twist is your hand up
again or if you're not taking it down
i can't take it down and i can't raise
it either if you could do that for me
cheering up
okay thank you all right are there any
further questions
um if not well thank the officers for
their very um comprehensive report
and move to the next item
[Music]
so i think what the recommendation is
that we note the report is that
um is that the recommendation
yes thank you chair yeah so the
recommendation is to note the
report is that is that approved to any
dissenters from that
okay the next item is
um
[Music]
item eight item nine which is starter
fine
finance report pages 41-74
of your pack that's over to david
hodgson for that
hi uh thank you chair um
this is uh the report on the first
quarter uh budget monitoring for
strata i'll just quickly run through
uh the budget monitoring report uh and
then
uh talk to you a little about the
statement of accounts which
have been signed off by the auditors so
in terms of the
first quarter um the company was given
6.6 million pounds
to run the it service for 20 20 21
and in the business plan we had
um projected that we would provide a
refund at the end of the year of 700
696 000 uh to the councils
obviously kovidus hit uh and your three
councils
um are uh struggling financially
there's uh been a significant drop in
income all three councils
as a result of the restrictions that
were were introduced
and therefore uh each of the councils
have been looking for savings
uh and reductions in year to to ensure
they have a balanced budget
strata the board and
the management team agreed
to look to identify some additional
savings
um to offer to the the
three councils and have identified an
additional
roughly 320 000 pounds um
that we can make in the year uh these
are in year savings
uh they're not long-term savings so it's
a result of delaying
some appointments of staff and
[Music]
and some better contract
renewals so we're looking to
deliver around a million pounds a gain
of
a refund to the three councils this year
at the first quarter we're about 50 000
short we're projecting
at the moment we believe we can make
that up
during the remainder of the year uh with
some additional
uh staffing changes that
are going to take place in the air
so we're still confident that we can
deliver that million pounds
um and just as a reminder uh the total
refund to the three councils last year
was uh a million and seventy three
thousand
so also attached to the report is the
statement of accounts
for uh 20 19 20
and i know there's some confusion as to
how the company's
profiting and loss can show a loss of a
million pounds
and yet the council provided a refund of
a million
pounds to the the council so
i will try and explain this
um this comes out
of the fact that we are a company
and not a council so the vast majority
of the loss the loss
relates to two main areas the first
is the fact that what the staff members
are members of the local government
pension scheme
and the local government pension scheme
is a defined benefit
scheme and
in a company that means that the cost
of the liabilities under a defined
benefit scheme
is shown on the balance sheet and the
changes in those costs
go through the profit and loss account
that's exactly the same for a council
but councils have a statutory override
to reverse
out those transactions and just
uh allow the the actual costs that they
make
to um to be put against the council tax
so it's a different way of of
providing the um the information and
it's based on
on accounting practice we ignore that
for the purposes of
of making the refund to the councils
because the three councils have given a
full guarantee
of the pension fund deficit
so therefore if strata
no longer existed the three councils
have agreed to take responsibility for
any pension fund deficit that there is
so therefore we we um we ignore that and
that's
the main reason why we can give the
refund of a million pounds
and yet show the loss in actual
fact last year our balance sheet
position as a company
improved because the pension fund
actually had a 1.9 million pound
increase in its uh its financial
position
so that unfortunately doesn't go through
the profit and loss account so it
doesn't show against the loss
but in overall terms um stratus balance
sheet
improved from a negative 6.3 million to
negative 5.3 million last year
i know that's quite difficult to
understand but uh
i'm happy to take any questions and try
and explain it a little better
if you have any further questions
i'm sorry i caught here
i turned myself off um no counselors
um have any questions so my question is
and this is because because we're a
private company the pension costs are
off balance sheet
but we know we have to pay for them at
the end which is why we show
them as a loss but we don't have to show
them that way for
for companies is that the answer no so
so for the company it's on balance sheet
it's absolutely there so
but for for councils we have a a made-up
reserve that offsets completely the
the pension fund deficit so if you look
at your council accounts if you
if you take extras i think we've got a
around 116 million pound
pension fund deficit we're allowed to
put a an equal and opposite amount on
the other side of the balance sheet to
balance it off
companies aren't allowed to do that but
the auditors are more than happy that
because we have the guarantee from the
three councils
that we can ignore that for the purposes
of the refund
all right thank you i get it now thank
you
any other questions
okay well thank um what do you want us
to do just note the report
yes okay um is that agreed that we just
note the report any dissenters
speak now
and in which case we move to item 10.
okay is that you too david
so a very short report here um which
just talks about the devon audit
partnership so we have a
an internal audit organization called
devon audit partnership who
work closely with strata to look at a
number of
areas of the strata service at the
beginning of the year they come up with
an audit plan
they then have an auditor who looks at
those areas works closely understands
how strata are performing
and then comes up with an overall
score of strata's performance and how
we're measured
the areas they looked at in 2019 2020
was the overall effectiveness of strata
they looked
at the project management and solution
delivery process so that very much
linked into the creation of the
strata it solution delivery team and
they looked at cyber security
those were the key areas they looked at
last year
every single one of those they
identified is of a good standard
but actually moving in a in the
direction of a very positive direction
with inside the good standards as well
um that actually concluded in the
annual report that they produced that
circulated out to
um the chief execs the strata board and
the jec and the jsc
and that gives an assurance level um and
they believe
that the authorities have substantial
assurance
that strata can fulfill their role
as the i.t services provider and that
there is the right level of internal
control framework in place
to ensure that strata as a business is
is supporting the work of the
authorities in a in a
in a very positive way so that's an
annual report
we've just looked at the draft report or
the draft areas that they're going to be
looking at next
next year and that what is being
presented to the starter board on friday
okay sir that was the end of that report
from myself okay thank you question
if you could come out of the um shared
screen i can see
hands up um um i can't see any
hands up
got somebody joining us from whatsapp is
that council clarence
our phone hello there i think i'm with
you again because my device
became totally intermittent chair i've
missed all the
financial directors report it was
intermittent throughout the
apologies there's nothing i could do so
i've been pretty useless member of this
committee i'm sorry okay thank you it's
good to hear that you're back
um by the a phone link um
any questions
just to say then it's all good news
we've already
phil you're waving
i suppose this is kind of a question
aimed at
the finance gurus can i be assured i
believe that's the term simon davey
can i be assured that the auditors are
very happy with the way that
strata is being run both financially and
in a business sense
am i assured by their reports on and
whoever
sorry dave
yeah come on start directly chair
yes yes sorry simon yeah no
um yes you can be assured assured is a
good level so
that's um that's pretty good in order to
speak um so the reports that
have been undertaken in terms of
internal reviews
um as lawrence has shown it is are good
reports
and obviously from a financial
perspective the accounts have now been
signed off so they are a true and
accurate view
of the financial position of strata so i
think you can be assured councillor
twist
thank you so much thank you
okay um so um if we're happy to note the
report
um we'll move on to the next item
and i'm now going to take item
seven which is local government access
to information act 1985
exclusion of press and public um and in
order to
um discuss this at a item we have to be
past this resolution um
and that is that under section 100 a
brackets 4 of the local government act
1972
the press and public be excluded from
the meeting for partic
for this next item on the grounds that
it involves
the likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph
three
of part one of schedule 12a of the act
they've got to do this for so um we have
to take you'd have to take a rogue call
do we
chair um we don't know we can pass this
but after this um after members agree to
this we'll have to stop live streaming
so we just have to um
okay microphones wait until the live
stream stopped
so um if anybody descends please can you
wave now
see no one waving so i assume that's
past so we'll now end the live
recording and ask anybody who's not a
member of this committee i think that's
councillor
paul miller what about what about
councillors um
who aren't part of the committee yes
that's you i'm afraid paul you've got to
go now
i don't think that's correct actually
yes it is i'm afraid yes i'm not i'm not
sure it is actually by law
i think councillors can stay in these
meetings
um a part a and part b means that even
if a counselor isn't on a committee um
they can still
look up the act i'm afraid you're wrong
chad well i'm going to ask for advice
i'm going to ask democratic services to
advise
and i'll follow their advice
um i'm sorry i can't advise on that
because i don't know
um i don't know what the law is but um
it would be
the members it would be for the
committee to vote if they wish
to it's not it's law um part a and part
b um look at the law it's um
all cap all elected members who who take
part in the meeting we're not the public
and the press i'm not a member of the
public i am not a member of the press
i'm a councillor
i should be allowed to stay for part b
thank you
i was advised at the beginning of this
meeting that you would have to leave the
meeting
so um chair the law has some clear
advice please
the law has changed with remote meetings
and i i don't know
um i'm sorry i can't advise on whether
we can
we can um exclude councillor miller or
not
if if we were um if we were in a normal
meeting in the council chambers and
the members can stay
members can stay exactly
okay
but you don't think that
i i suggest chairman on on this occasion
that the councillor remains
um in the meeting but um we do have to
stress that
it is everything we're discussing at the
moment is confidential
yeah and i certainly respect that but i
also know that the act
very specifically and i know 100
that i'm allowed to stay thank you
okay but counselor i was acting on the
advice i received at the beginning of
this meeting
i understand that and i wasn't uh
personally criticizing you as chair
thank you okay
fine are we ready to proceed then
chairs because it's can can we um just
hold fire
and mute because we um
we've got to confirm that we've stopped
live streaming i thought we had
but we just need to check that
you